now then one of the issues that also
looks set to dominate the next year's
politics is the promised referendum of
course on Britain's membership of the
European Union in an interview this
morning Mr Cameron says he will rule
nothing out if he doesn't get his way in
renegotiations with the EU labour has
promised to campaign for the party to
stay in Europe no matter which way the
Prime Minister's discussions go i'm
joined out by the shadow europe minister
Pat McFadden and a very good morning to
you still fun I know you SAT there
listening to that conversation I was
having mr. Lewis it'd just be interested
to get you'll take on Syria and the
Labour Party position if faced with a
vote in the House of Commons on
extending British military activities
from Iraq into Syria we know there's a
strong ground swell within the party to
say no isn't that now bolstered by the
further complications of Russian
military action there well I think we
need to look at the proposal if it comes
we took a vote of a year ago in the
House of Commons to support airstrikes
against Isis in Iraq but not in Syria
for my part I've always wondered what
the moral justification was of coming to
the aid of the victims of Isis in Iraq
but not in Syria this is after all
aboard oh they don't recognize at all in
the caliphate that they are trying to
build so I don't begin from the premise
that extending the air campaign to Syria
is impossible but obviously the actions
that the Russians have taken in recent
days of complicated matters they are I
think we'd have to ask what exactly is
it the further action by British forces
would contribute to a situation like
this with the Russians and the Americans
in different ways already engaged there
I don't have an in-principle objection
to doing this because I agree with
Julian that Isis represents a huge
danger to us in terms of values and our
way of life that responding to that
should not rule things out militarily
but I think we'd have to see exactly
what the proposal was and what it was
expected to add well thanks that myself
and let's get on to the issue of Europe
and again the labor position let's try
to work
try and bring some clarity to me because
the Prime Minister now saying that if he
doesn't get what he wants in
renegotiations he rules nothing out now
one of the things he might want in
renegotiations are dealing with
employment rights and some of the the
red tape as they describe it surrounding
those issues but we've heard from Labour
say well if they go some of us or all of
us or the whole party might actually
campaign for out is that the case that's
not the position nor Oh some of our
friends in the trade unions have quite
rightly said the GM BGA via those have
quite rightly said Europe is an
important source of social protection
and rates for people at work one thinks
of the rates to paid leave equal rates
for part-time workers
anti-discrimination measures and so on
that's been quite a lot over the years
so what they've said is we don't want
the Prime Minister to grab these things
up as part of his renegotiation no
neither do i I think that would be wrong
and so you wanted to fail no I told him
to feel oh you want him to fail err that
you vote for it and he'd be voting for
out and it's very confident it's not
really that complicated because the
question on the ballot paper is remain
or leave the one maybe is not on the
ballot paper if the Prime Minister was
unwise enough to try and rip up
everybody's employment rates as part of
his renegotiation and by the way it's
not clear at all that that's going to
happen i'm not you know he certainly
didn't mention that on any interviews
not here today but if he did that the
rate response wouldn't be to leave the
European Union because then by
definition people at work wouldn't have
access to any EU aid employment rates
because we outside the European Union
the rate response to that would be for
us to campaign subsequent election to
opt by councillors measures and we've
done this before when the social chapter
the original through you weighed
employment rates a piece of all this was
put in place the conservative governor
at the time under john major opted out
of it they said they didn't want to sign
up to that we disagreed with that in
opposition we said we would opt in to
that chapter if we got elected and
that's precisely what we did when we won
power and we couldn't have done that if
we've been outside the European Union so
for us this position we don't
want to see the employment rates
diminished but the in principal position
in the referendum is very clear and was
confirmed at a conference last week we
will campaign and Alan Johnson's been
appointed to lead the labor campaign on
this for Britain to remain in the
European Union when the referendum comes
okay let me just talk to this overall
about the party in your leaders actions
tomorrow going up to join demonstrations
in protests I mean there is a convention
by and large that is held pertained in
British politics that you don't really
queer the pictures leader for somebody
else's party conference mr. Corbin
deciding to go to Manchester join some
of these protests I mean do you think
that in itself is perhaps treading too
much on on their toes and also rather
underlines the difference between your
parties there is one party taking
decisions that affect the very future of
the country international affairs and
mr. Corbin is outside with a lot of
people shouting impotently well for me
it's not about conventions I mean
conventions that they are sometimes
they're broken or not but I think the
second part of your your question is
what I'd like to address mr. Corbin is a
person who if you like spent his
background in protest movements and
going to lots of demonstrations and so
on there is a culture of protest in the
Labour Party has always been there going
back many decades and you know it has
its place but government is different
from protest and you know what I want to
see is a party that can get elected and
can implement change and everything that
we've managed to achieve be it from the
creation of the NHS to the introduction
of the minimum wage has been based on
being able to win elections and there's
a difference between being a party
protest and a party of government and I
think one of the important things for
him is to make that transition as a
politician from one protest to one at
least potentially of government because
they're not the same thing and what I
don't want to see is the Labour Party's
job description being changed from being
either a party of government or at least
contesting elections seriously to become
a party of government
to being satisfied with just being a
protest movement because that would be a
fundamental change in our job
description and a relationship with a
British people and that's not something
I want to see